welcome back everyone so we're very
lucky to have an afternoon full of Nazis
very sorry I have you for the remaining
I think words until 8:00 p.m. okay we
will take a break or two actually can we
take two bricks and since it's
interpreters we have to stick to their
okay okay so thanks what I'll be talking
about this entire afternoon is it's
things that have been already came up in
this workshop quite a bit and this is
the this sometimes implicit bias is
introduced by the optimization algorithm
that are even though are may be phrased
in terms just minimizing the the
training error minimizing some objective
are actually in inducing a lot of very
helpful biases into the into the system
and just to motivate well what we mean
by that one so that's important in deep
learning I'll see some slides that we
actually already saw today not today but
this week I think it's some version of
this plot already appeared this week and
what we see here is the training error
and tests are for training on em nest
data training the neural networks
increasing size and what we see is that
this is when use the larger net larger
networks the training error goes down to
zero eventually it reaches zero but what
should be a bit maybe surprising here is
that the the test error continues
decreasing well past the point that the
training error is already zero okay and
so looking at this and I should say that
the way this was trained was just by
minimizing the training error and what
should be surprising about this is two
things one thing is that this continues
going down so why is this continued
going down it's not going down because
we're approximating the
the data better so if it's going down
it's probably because we're finding
solution that's better in some other
sense okay and so what other since I
mean it seems that that there is some
kind of implicit thing going on here
that's when we have larger and larger
networks is biasing a sort into its
solution that are better in some sense
the second thing we should be surprised
here is even if we just look at a single
point here like I think around the
thousand networks of with the thousand
here there are already many many more
parameters here than training data
points and so over here there's
absolutely no reason that our by
minimizing the training error will be
able to actually fit we'll be able to
generalize I mean we we really should be
what we should be expecting is this to
shoot way up okay
and so even just to focusing a single
point you should ask why is it that the
optimization here actually finds a
solution that can that generalizes and
this is said we saw this earlier this
isn't not in some sense a new phenomena
a similar type of thing was was observed
in boosting again we saw this plots
earlier this week and also boosting
wasn't initially understood in terms of
finding a sparse predictor predictor
that's only uses a small number of weak
classifiers and so the kind of
generalization ability was in terms of
the the sparsity in terms of that's kind
of the explicit bias there's you know
how many a weak predictors I'm using but
when you actually run boosting you see
that even if using many many more you
continue running boosting and you have
using many many more weak predictors
much more that's actually needed in
order to fit the data so you're not
getting any better data fit here
the test error keeps decreasing and so
what's going on here again there's
something else that's not explicit in
the optimization algorithm and you're
viewing here at the boost is an
optimization algorithm that's actually
driving what's going on and this has
been understood in series of papers are
starting from seminal paper by Peter and
co-authors in 1998 which showed that
what's going on here is that what we're
doing when we're continuing running
boosting is we're increasing the l1
margin so this is plot that we already
saw they all want margin after the
distribution of the kind of the martin
margin after so this
Elwin margin after five iterations and
after a hundred and thousand iterations
that we get increasingly larger and
larger lo1 margins and so the
explanation of what's the what's going
on here the reason we're getting very
realization is because some complexity
control is improving in this case the l1
norm in so if we go back to our plot
from the first finger and zoom in and
what's going on so this is only the I'm
not plotting here the training error
because this is where the training error
is already zero then we can say well
maybe there's some complexity control
kind of maybe analogous to the l1 norm
and in boosting that actually is being
decreased as we increase the the width
and in fact you can kind of come up with
various complexity measures what I'm
plotting here is the pass norm and not
even gonna tell you what it is it
doesn't matter it's not the right thing
that's going on here and you should view
this more as a cartoon the object I
think venom agrees right okay I mean we
since up some other suggesting I don't I
don't want to get into that but the
point is that we we expect kind of
define models are becoming more and more
they're becoming more complex in terms
of number of units but they're cutting
more and more simple in terms of
something else like maybe the the path
or maybe something else so one question
we could ask and this is not the main
question we're gonna ask in this
tutorial East is what is this complexity
measure that's actually controlling
generalization and that was addressed a
bit in Sasha and Peter's tutorials were
discussed in various ways that we can
ensure generation for networks even with
number of units is much much bigger than
number founder is much much bigger than
the number of training points but the
question we're going to ask here is a
bit of a different question so again if
we focus on this networks with the width
2000 then what we're finding we're
running so the way we trained this venom
how do we train this is gradient you
remember I mean mini-batch gradient
descent on the training objective until
convergence okay and so what we told the
optimization algorithm to do is minimize
the training error and they did minimize
the training error to find the global
minimum of the training error how do I
know I found global minimum for training
error so now it's a zero okay it's
definitely global minima okay so the
optimization algorithm did what it's
supposed to do and when it found a
solution that
actually generalized well a small tester
and also had small paths nerve okay so
now the question is wider to do that so
as we said there are many many more
parameters here than training points so
this is not the only global optimum
there are many global Optima many of
these global Optima I do not have small
path arms so now I'm going to pluck
several other globe LACMA each one of
those red dots corresponds to global
Optima so if the optimization algorithm
outputted any one of those red dots I
would not be able to complain it the
optimization algorithm did what it was
supposed to do it found the solution
with zero training error in zero and
then also training loss that's
essentially zero okay but yet not all of
these points have small Pastner in fact
these global minima all have very high
path norm and in fact they also
generalize horribly suggesting and maybe
the pattern has something to do with
generalization yeah and then I could get
the same thing if they plotted some
other complexity measures here as well
so the real question we're going to ask
is what why is it that our optimization
algorithm actually did something that
seems kind of sensible and what does it
mean even to be sensible and we turn
this this global Optima which is a good
global Optima and not these global
Optima which are bad global Optima and
note that that may be what we're going
to focus a lot this what does it mean to
be a good global Optima so when you
think of it in terms of optimization a
good global Optima what's a good
government look a good solution is a
solution that has small objective in
particular global Optima is good that
kind of a definition okay so and what
does it mean to be good about on a
global firm all of these are equally
good in terms of the optimization
they're all doing a job in terms of
optimization but there's some other
property some implicit properties that
are not specified when we said okay
minimize this training objective that
are actually that they're different
between them okay so how is it that the
optimization algorithm well you know
what is the optimization already
implicitly doing and how is it doing
that in particular if we said that the
choice of yes as I said I don't want to
answer that question I mean I mean it's
I mean if you ask the answer it's this
sum over all computation parts and
network of the product of the weights
along the path taking in this case
squared okay I mean it really for the
purpose of this it doesn't matter some
measure of first magnitude of the
weights in the system yeah
so yeah vitaliy is this two points that
there is a zero training error and they
release it and the fact that we're using
maybe some explicit motion oh these are
not these are two unrelated phenomena
like the fact that you there is some you
could you might as well know they're not
they're not unrelated in the sense that
if there is a unique global minima if
the problem was not so this is an
undetermined problem so it's been the
title slide I think I think that helped
my talk with something like rhythmic
bison underdetermined systems so it's
important here is that the system is
under determined the system was over
determined then generally speaking
there'll be a unique global minima and
then if I tell the optimization
algorithm minimize the the training
objective it would not have any
flexibility in what it does there'll be
only one good answer one correct answer
which is a global minimum no you're
right okay notice the second second
you're right that the important thing is
not whether the training error is zero
or not the question is whether it is a
unique minima or not
the thing is in general okay for systems
and in general so think of the oil and
we'll get to the specific example ad or
think of a least square problem in
general position okay for least square
power in general position either there's
a unique global minima that's a nun
that's nonzero or there are many global
minima they're all zero so you're you're
right that I can contrive all kinds of
situations that what the state and I
said just said is correct okay right
okay you're right that I can have all
kinds of situations where there are
various degeneracies so that there are
many global many minimum many global
minima that are not zero that's fine
okay I I mean I I then that these the
reasons will apply as well but no I
didn't say balance your sit-downs what
I'm saying is I'm not we'll see later on
whether it's about to not and we'll talk
about that but right now there's no
balance I'm minimizing the training
error in among the solute among the
global optimum of the training ER and
all of these are there's no balance
between
all of these I have zero training err
among the solutions of zero training err
I'm selecting between them one that has
maybe small pattern you can do the same
thing with among those that have 50%
training they're like nothing good like
you could define among solutions that ok
this is this is an important thing that
I think will come up later you're saying
well I could have used a completely
different procedure and explicitly done
something done all kinds of Frogger
ization and choose kind of things and
balance the questionnaire with one of
the things we're going to talk about
today no I know wonderfully kind of
Thursday is not in this will do this
will be a relevant question asked for
almost everything we're going to show
because almost everything we're showing
back we're going to show it explicitly
there is an explicit way of achieving
the same thing in fact one the the goals
of what we're doing is the thing that's
happening here explicitly we would like
to have an explicit procedure of the
does it and so but rather are the what
the way to kind of interpret this talk
is an attack that doesn't at this point
not a talk that that starts with the
problem and suggests a good solution for
the problem but the talk that starts
with a solution what people actually do
okay so that's a given but people
actually do in this case is minimize if
training err okay that's what we did
here
hey that's what venom did you can just
minimize the training girl you can't
change that okay and now we're trying to
understand what actually happened when
you do that procedure okay like it's not
the only way to investigate the same
implicit regulation right doesn't happen
is a very broad thing and in fact we'll
see will the explicit talk about it also
in the none zero loss yes you're right
margin okay so so because we will in
fact talk about non realizable cases in
cases we don't have zero loss we'll talk
about all this but the the the the
phenomena I'm talking about here is a
phenomena where you have zero loss okay
I'm still I'm not sure what the
objection is I
okay okay sure that's a good point
that's very hard okay so you might think
that what we did here is instead of
using your batch gradient descent we
used some other really bad optimization
algorithm however it's really difficult
to get you know any any optimization I
mean you can think of food actually
fairly scent be fairly sensible and
would get maybe wouldn't get this point
it'll get points that are kind of over
here so you have to really put in a lot
of effort to get these points so the way
what it's not that hard
well I mean you know it's it's if you
want to just have a to design a synth
and you're unnatural it's hard to do
with the natural polymerization of it
okay so what we did you know maybe I'll
tell the solution well it's not it's not
an algorithm you'd never use at home so
what we did is okay so imagine you're
you're telling me you're calling I'm the
optimizer you're calling you're giving
me a training set and telling me find
the global often on this training set
and they will return to your global
optimum this training set the way I do
it remember that have many more
parameters and then your training points
I'm gonna collect a bunch more points
from the distribution and label them
incorrectly and then minimize the
training error on the points you gave me
Plus this confusion set I'm going to get
something has zero training around the
on your training set plus the confusion
set in particular else as your training
on your training set then I'm going to
turn it to you it's a perfectly valid
global minima for your training set but
it's it's really bad okay so in that
sense it's not like a natural
optimization if you I hope your code
your optimization code doesn't actually
do this okay but but but we'll get to
know in my noggin
maybe I mean this is supposed to be just
a motivation I didn't even start the
talk yet I think we are gonna be here
until you came okay so
but is that what we're going to look at
is what wait I mean how does
optimization algorithm actually select
this one and not these horrible ones in
particular if we change optimization
algorithm okay we're gonna change this
implicit bias we're gonna have different
solutions and and they're gonna have
different utilization properties because
we're gonna maybe minimize something
else so maybe you're not gonna get these
horrible ones and now maybe to ask off
this question now we try different
reasonable algorithms and see what we
get so this is we try two different
algorithms here I mean one is standard
sqd and the other is the approximate
steepness the Senate with respect to
this path norm it doesn't matter just
think of it as the blue algorithm in the
red algorithm okay so here in the blue
algorithm the red algorithm on the
training objective which is the
multi-class logistic regression loss
these days called the cross entropy loss
and what we see is that doesn't actually
find a global minimum of zero solution
maybe the blue one a bit faster but it
doesn't that's not so important however
when we go to the to the test
performance we see a big difference
between them okay so the the both of
them found a global minima but the blue
out they found different global minima
and the blue algorithm found a better
global minima and this is consistently
wrong among training sets among all
kinds of different variations here which
withdraw pots without droplets and I'm
going to talk about this another
comparison is again a blog on red
algorithm this case the grid algorithm
blue algorithm is that a stochastic
gradient descent and the red algorithm
is Adam it's to castigate ascend with
momentum and the adaptive vapor
coordinate step sizes it doesn't really
matter just think of it as a red Algar
and blue algorithm in this case if i
just this is if i'm an optimization
person i'm only looking at the left hand
plot here and the left hand plot
actually suggests the red algorithm is
better okay it's it comes it's
converging faster in fact I didn't I
should have extended eventually they're
going to reach the same training error
and the red algorithm is finding that
terminal training error faster but the
solutions are the group that the the
optimum now I can not completely sure
it's a global or I'm pretty sure it's a
global Optima it's converging here is
that it's converging to is actually
worse okay in what sense it's worse in
terms of optimization it's it's just as
good but it's generalizing what much
worse it has been westernization so it
seems the implicit bias of these two
optimization algorithms are different
which is leading to completely different
generalization properties okay so when
I'm so the general thing we're seeing
here is
that if you think of the optimization
landscape there are many global minima
over the term all of these problems are
over determined so if we fit confusing
neural networks are used today you know
our our way over determined there
generally have many many more parameters
than the training examples so there are
many go block there are many CRS
solutions we're optimizing the training
error but what's really important is not
just that we're optimizing the training
error but which of these global minima
you're going to get to in fact what I'd
argue is that the networks are where
look using are large enough that
conceptually you can think of them as
infinite size networks okay they're
they're close enough to infinity in
particularly couldn't represent all
functions okay in in and I can say that
because it's very least they can present
all functions on your training day you
know I think it's correct to think of
them as really can represent all
functions so just limiting the fact that
use a specific model does not actually
constrain your model class so in the in
sascha and in Peters tutorial the the
focus was when you define some model
class you define some your hypothesis
class and you learn by you you gain
generalization by limiting the capacity
of this model class but the model class
here is all functions so that's not how
we're we're gaining generalization
instead whatever argue is that we're
finding a particular a particular zero
error solution so just think of it this
way
that you have your landscape way over
parameters problem you have lots of zr
solutions these are the oceans okay and
you're going to start optimizing
somewhere so where are you gonna get
you're not gonna get in the middle of
the ocean and you're not you're gonna
because your optimization is going to
kind of be all our optimization
procedures are essentially STD or
variants there's some local optimization
procedure you're gonna get to a beach
okay the zero solution on the beach okay
but which beach so if you start
optimizing in berkeley and you go down
you're gonna get against optimizing here
you're gonna get to the bait okay if you
start optimizing in boston you're going
to go down you're gonna give them a
situation speak the question is what
happens we start optimizing in Chicago
okay so Chicago is really flat you can
get anywhere in the rivers flow
backwards and you can get like you know
you in the now that really depends which
way do you does your optimization
algorithm prefer doing going if your
optimization algorithm prefer going it
prefers going north-south prefers going
south you'll get to the Gulf of Mexico
if your optimization algorithm prefers
going north you'll get to the San
Lawrence okay and so if your
optimization
prefers going east and with some
difficulty you'd get to the Atlantic
Ocean okay so it's really it depends
what are the biases of your optimization
algorithm biases of termination
algorithm will determine which solution
you're going to get to and that will
really determine your the behavior model
so let's I mean maybe this seems
abstract and you don't believe me that's
seen in a very concrete problem which we
can actually understand if you start to
close maybe but I maybe will save that
question and when we talk about it then
okay but okay okay so let's let's think
about the problem and so neural nets
they don't understand nobody understands
but there's one problem I need to
understand that's matrix factorization
okay in particular matrix completion so
I've seen of metrics completion problem
so I'm its completion role it's written
here and the more general form is kind
of reconstructing their measurement and
metrics W based on linear measurements
but if these linear measurements are
just indicators you can think of it as a
metrics completion you observe some of
the entries metrics you want to complete
the rest of the entries so we can think
of this we're gonna write this as this
least square problems where we have our
observations we want to minimize there
what our training objective is going to
be just minimize the error and
observations okay and W is going to be
all possible matrices and by n matrices
in this case and of course metrics
completion is interesting if you have
much fewer observations then then then
parameter I do have N squared parameters
and I ever seem gonna have only C's part
of the entries so even aimed in our
observations is much much smaller
where's it written here okay much much
smaller than the the number of
parameters yeah so this is the problem
we're gonna solve okay so if I solve
this as an optimization problem this is
a really stupid optimization problem how
would you solve this optimization
problem hmm picking on you say how would
you solve this optimization problem what
what you put 0 K the easiest thing to do
you put you just but you put 0
everywhere another don't reason complete
observed entries you've got your
solution so it's very easy to solve this
optimization problem okay this is of
course not
only go block but there are many global
offices optimization problem okay you
can complete the observed entries and
put the Fibonacci sequence anywhere else
complete observable entries input 73
every row similar stats of global Optima
okay the question is which go block more
are you going to get to okay so if you
do this you're going really nice and and
double you're actually gonna I'm going
to get to a very interesting global
minima but to get to something
interesting what we're gonna do is we're
gonna change our model without changing
the model class okay so they can we're
gonna emphasize here or the model class
is important but but the model is
important and not because of the model
class so we're gonna do this problem
doesn't make any sense it has way too
many parameters we're gonna do exactly
what we do in deep learning which is we
have a probably way too many parameters
so we're going to make even more
parameters okay so we're going to over
over parameterize this and serving of N
squared parameters we're going to have 2
N squared parameters okay so we're going
to write W is U times V ok so now we
have n 2 N squared parameters U and V
are full dimension they're both N by n I
did not limit my model class at all I'm
talking about exactly same model class
because all the func all the metrics is
w I can write as u times V in fact
around u times V in many different ways
right W times identity identity times W
in a bunch of other different ways ok so
this problem is just as stupid as the
previous one there are many different
global minima sibs global minimize
perfectly valid and you know there are
the global minima are also valid but
nevertheless we're going to take this
completely stupid golden problem and
we're going to solve it with gradient
descent and over over U and V and the
question is what happens ok I think many
of you at this point of seen is before
so what happens is as follows so what we
see here we're comparing two things this
is a gradient descent on the original
matrix W so this is the the kind of not
very good interesting thing of doing and
this is grading Center factorization so
again this is the same optimization
problem solved in two different ways the
training object are in both cases is
zero we fit observed entries big deal
it's very easy to fit observe entries
what should be more surprising is that
the test error so in this how well we're
doing in the unobserved entries is very
different if we just do this the
grannies send and metrics W itself then
the test error is as we expected really
horrible we're not doing anything but if
we actually do granny sin and U and V
then we actually get pretty good
performance really good test performance
so we actually succeed in actually
constructing new metrics and I should
say that I mean this works because the
metrics itself had actually some
structures and it processes simulation
and approximately in approximate low
rank matrix but
know that the model itself doesn't know
this they didn't actually limit my
search to approach to low rank
mattresses okay but nevertheless just by
the fact we're we're optimizing or every
we managed actually generalizing well
okay so this is migrating sent with
exact line search okay now let's change
optimization algorithm we're gonna
change optimization algorithm to be a
worse optimization algorithm okay which
were supplementation algorithm instead
of doing gradients in the exact line
search in the beginning we're gonna do
gradient sent with a fixed small step
size in terms of optimization that's the
worst optimization algorithm put my
optimization hat on I did something the
bad because I'm just gonna take me much
longer to actually I'm sending a
converging global minima it's very easy
to get to go minima it's gonna take me
longer to get to the build minima but in
terms of generalization performance this
change of optimization algorithm
actually that's a better translation
performance so so roughly you should
think of these things is these this is
these points that were in the top right
the points that done make any sense
they're really bad okay they're global
minima but they're really bad global
minima this is actually global minima
that are actually sensible and now we
changed a bit optimization algorithm we
get global minima that are even more
sensible that are better so what's you
know what's going on here can we
so again so this is I hope it the
connection to what we saw at the
beginning is clear we have a system
that's completely over determined it's
essentially the set of all functions in
this case all functions meaning all
matrices okay so we're not limiting at
all our model class nevertheless just
because we were optimizing we're finding
our optimization is leading us to a
beach that actually makes sense okay and
and so what's going on here what is the
beach we're finding here and in this
case we can kind of say what is the
beach we're finding and so we'll get
back to that later but roughly speaking
there is there's some evidence that what
we're finding is the minimum nuclear
norm solution okay so what we've got
here is also the mirakuru so nuclear
norm solution in this case and you can
see that this is in the nuclear norm of
different solutions if we do grandniece
and with small step size we actually do
find the minimum nuclear arm solution
okay
and so so in this case i would say that
the implicit bias of the optimization
algorithm which is grainy send an u and
v is given by the nuclear or me so
that's and that's the part we're trying
to get today what is the implicit bias
of the optimization algorithm and then
we know that that's a good of two
implicit bias because actually
minimizing the nuclear norm if u is a
good way of recovering your
Oxana teal orange matrix that we already
knew before okay into what we're going
to do today is try to make this
connection with an optimization
algorithm and implicit bias okay and
again I mean going back to new let's I
mean what this suggests is you know I
hope at this point I convinced you that
actually optimization algorithm is
important then it means that if you if
you have you know the classic structure
learning paper we come up with some
model class the model class is great and
then we say well how are you going to
train in this model class well we're
just going to minimize the training
error okay and so and how do we minimize
the training error it's not important we
just use some minor them something it's
the details and appendix are in the code
or something else okay so what I'm
trying to say is that your entire
learning algorithm your entire like
inductive vice or entire everything
that's going on what determines which
Martin what predict you're actually
going to find is not given by your model
okay because your model likely can model
every function okay but rather is given
by the details of a permutation
algorithm and so in order to understand
what we actually doing we have to
understand this disconnection okay okay
good so any question about before I
start the talk ok good ok ok ok so what
we're going to do in the first half
roughly just probably a bit more than
half we're going to go and look at
convex shell learning which we actually
understand many of these things and
understand implicit bias and in Sheldon
you'll actually understand more broadly
so we're gonna what we're gonna
emphasize is the connection between dope
to music the geometry of optimization
and geometry of learning and try to get
a geometrical view of all this and
hopefully make you make it clear what I
mean and then we're gonna go to deep
learning and if we have time which you
probably want we'll probably also talk a
bit about the kernel and deep regimes
and how they effective this advice so
let's start with convex problems to
understand in what how can relate
optimization and learning in a deep
connection to optimizations earning for
convex problems and the importance of
optimization particularly the the
geometry when I'm training and excite
and emphasize no this is really what's
important is what is the geometry of
optimization that your bias comes from
the geometry of your
the optimization and I'll soon make it
clear what I mean
but let's in order to understand that
let's just think of what is what is
learning okay so what it's the goal of
learning I'm going to focus specifically
on supervised learning about supervised
learning is just find a predictor it has
which has a good expected error on the
under the population and the only
problems we actually don't know the
distribution of population so instead
what we do we collect a bunch of samples
and we can construct an empirical
estimate for our population objective
and why is this not showing here okay
and and then what we do is we minimize
the empirical error the mean stuff
minimizing the population which we can
measure empirical error so this supposed
optimization problem and now to ensure
good utilization we can either limit to
somebody potus's class or add some
regular Lizer and really this is usually
what's in your therapist the main kind
of bias of learning and i should say
that i'm not going to distinguish too
much between them because adding oops
this should be sine not 5v I'm sorry
this this is right okay
so adding a regularizer is almost the
same as constraining two sublevel sets
of sight so throughout the talks will
sometimes be more convenient for us to
talk about like restricting to sub level
sets of the regularizer and sometimes
talk about adding a penalty minimizing
the regulator the point isn't much of
learning bows down to solving one of
these two problems like minimizing a
regular lights problem or a constraint
problem where the bias is determined by
this sigh so if I talk sighs now it's
going to determine our bias order which
later will refer to also is a
optimization and then how are you gonna
current t generalization so if you were
here for Peter and Sasha stalks a
classic way to determine utilization is
we can have instead this uniform
convergence in the sub level sets of sy
if we establish in from convergent sub
level set subside we find a solution
with small size and we know that our
population objective is also going to be
as good as our training objective great
so let's look at a concrete example and
a concrete example we'll look at is
probably the kind of most
straightforward example here is roughly
you can think of it as SVM's
this is ill to regularize predictions or
predictors are given by linear
predictors in a very high maybe in
different dimensional space so again we
don't get much inductive bias from from
delimiting this the the just two linear
predictors but instead what we're going
to do is we limited only two predictors
are small in Euclidean norm so in this
case our sub level sets are just
Euclidean balls okay and we're also
going to assume here that the data is
normalized in our loss function is 1
Lipschitz like hinge loss or logistic
cost or something like that so what can
we do in this case if we in fact solve
this erm problem then we minimize the
loss inside we find the particular
minimizes minimizing the empirical
losses empirical risk minimizer and now
we can rely on uniform convergence
sources we saw in the previous two days
and the uniform converges tells us that
the empirical error of w hat is going to
be close to an expectation to within
something that scale is something that
looks like square root of norm squared
over m m is number of samples and so you
can guarantee that the predictor we find
is gonna compete with the best thing in
our class best thing with small nor up
to this square root of norm squared over
n ok so now the question is how do we
solve this optimization problem or even
optimization problems on talk about
optimization how we solve this
optimization problem oh we can solve it
with gradient descent ok just take the
gradient of the empirical oops saying
offseason tations gonna change so to
talk this point okay we're gonna later
call this LS but for now we'll call it L
hat ok so we're just gonna minimize our
empirical objective iteratively sorry
minimize empirical objective by taking
her batch gradient descent and now we
can ask well how long is it gonna take
us to optimize in a number of first we
can get new standard gratings and
guarantee tells us that after T
iterations we're going to be within
square root of B squared over T close to
the to the minimum of this empirical
objective so we already seen here that
look we have the same quantities here
that's kind of interesting but they're
bounding different things ok this is a
generalization guarantee that comes from
uniform convergence this is a sub
optimality guarantee on how close is the
empirical objective that we're finding
to the minimum possible empirical
objective ok so this is great need
essentially use gradient sent here yes
No
come on I was warned that the people are
not very sound very interactive but I
guess I can so what should we actually
use here how would you actually optimize
this how do you optimize the empirical
objective here with SGD thank you said
okay we instead of grading said of
course we should use stochastic gradient
ascent so use to caste gradient descent
advantages now we don't have to look at
each step on involves a single point and
not the entire batch so in each
iteration we just point choose the point
X I Y I and perform a step just on that
X I Y I and the important thing is that
the the gradient that we're using here
is or the gradient estimate we're using
here is an unbiased estimator of the
overall gradient and the magic is that
even if users really in this case we
still have to just do the same number of
iteration so we saved a lot okay this is
still an optimization guarantee okay now
what we actually want is we're not
actually going to find W hat we're gonna
find this W bar T like what happens
after T iterations of gradient descent
and we're gonna ask how well is this
gonna do on the population that's what
we actually care about because this is
gonna be the output of our algorithm and
we care how well it generalizes so what
we can do is we can just we have two
sources of error the optimization there
which is given by this and uniform
convergence error so the estimation
error which is given by this we add them
together and we get that overall we'll
find a predictor that has excess error
that competes with the best in class
with something X square root of B
squared over m to the square root of B
squared over T so if you set T roughly
equal to M word we're good you okay but
this is one way to approach this but
actually we didn't have to do all this
why is that so what we did here is we
viewed stochastic gradient descent as a
way of optimizing an empirical objective
but in another way to think about pretty
much the same iterations is to think of
stochastic grading centers the way of
utilizing them the population objective
after all okay every what we need for
stochastic gradient to work is that
every every grading estimate we're using
is an unbiased estimator of the gradient
of the objective so it's true that each
one of these points is unbiased estimate
of the empirical objective but is at
least if we use independent samples at
each iteration
each one of these gradient estimates is
also an unbiased estimate of the
population objective so that means we
can also use viewers Judy as a direct
optimization procedure on
population objective okay and now we can
apply the the STD sub optimality
guarantee directly to the population
objective so we no longer need the end
of the uniform convergence guarantee we
directly see I'm hoping that this is not
very new to most of you but I still want
to go through this carefully we get
directly from the from the optimization
guaranteed that the sub optimality on
the population loss which is exactly
what we wanted okay and in in its square
root of B squared over T and the thing
is that this works only if we use each
each point only once because we need
independent soundlessly generation so
the number of samples here is the number
has to match the number of iterations so
T has to be equal to M and we cover
recover the exact same guarantee okay so
what did we actually do here so so first
of all we see that we can get using an
optimization algorithm which is
stochastic gradient descent I I just ran
stochastic gradient Sen and actually
this gave me the same thing as what I
got by explicit rigorous action ok so
first of all let's let's try to take a
step back and see what's going on here
what's going on here is that if we think
of stochastic optimization what is to
cast economization so SGD is a method
first for stochastic optimization and
the standard phrase in stochastic
optimization we have an optimization
objective and and this optimization
objective is given as an expectation or
some of her over instantaneous objective
in what we do at each iteration is
instead of actually using the the
overall the true objective capital f we
just used unbiased estimators for it
okay and and so we can think of the
overall objective as the empirical
objective but we can also think of the
overall objective is the population
objective so in particular if you think
about our learning problems and said
what is our learning problem or a
learning problem was minimizing a
objective which is the the error on the
population this is exactly a problem
which is of the form of the stochastic
optimization problem okay so this is I
think something very important to keep
in mind that learning on it on its the
supervised learning at least is a
stochastic optimization problem okay so
it's not that when you solve this the
learning problem you solve the learning
problem and then you use some
optimization procedure to help you solve
the learning problem but the learning
problem itself is a stochastic
optimization problem and so what we said
so so what we saw is we will have its
discuss with musician Brown we just used
to customers indirectly to solve it okay
maybe I'll skip this but you can also
say that you know here we saw that
supervised learning is a special case of
stochastic optimization you can talk
about general learning which is exactly
equivalent to stochastic optimization
and so really I mean the my main I was
actually talking just over the lunch
break with Sascha but at what point was
this really understood and definitely
when I was you know when I was growing
up learning and optimization was kind of
studied as two separate things I think
in the last 15 years they've been merged
much more together through a very deep
understanding that you at this point I
think that hopefully this is not like
news to any of you that machine learning
is a stochastic optimization problem so
the community knows immersion really at
this point the difference between them
is mostly still boils down to notation
so we're gonna stick mostly with the
nips notation here if W when really this
is the same problem okay let me skip
this because okay so okay so let's go
back to what we saw before really what
we had is that we had two different
approaches here the first approach we
saw is we solved in an erm problem
empirical risk minimization problem and
so we have to make sure that we actually
limit ourselves to predictably small
norm and we could do that by actually
projecting all the time to have small to
make sure we stay with this in the
sublevel set and then we used SGD in
order to optimize empirical objective
okay
the trend of approach we showed it has
almost the same iterations isn't we say
okay now these iterations they just view
them as stochastic gradient on the
population objective itself okay and so
they're the the main difference between
them is that here we need a first temple
each iteration and here we can separate
between the number of iterations we have
in a number of steps we have we can may
take more steps number of iterations we
don't need to in terms of regulation of
an implicit versus explicit organization
which is the reason while I'm showing
you all this is that here the regulation
was very very explicit our bias was very
explicit how we limit to how he get
generalization was very very explicit we
get generalization
by restricting the l2 norm okay so this
is our explicit or explicit organization
our explicit bias and everything is kind
of on the table over here it's implicit
where is this hiding here I mean I'm
just doing stochastic granny sent in
what way am i you know I'm actually
regularizing the problem just searching
over all possible linear predictors
there are two way too many linear
predictors okay somehow the fact that
I'm doing it with these specific updates
allows me to get good generalization
okay skip this and in so we can do that
by limiting another way to think about
it is instead of doing erm when a
constraint problem this is maybe the
more familiar form we can also it also
perfectly fine to the root to look at
the regular I see are M so 2 this also
can guarantee generalization but here
again so this amounts to doing weight
decay and again here the the regulation
is very explicit its explicit here its
explicit in the weight decay and so it's
no we can get good generalization but
you're true of uniform convergence or
stability or something like that that
explicitly looks at this regularizer
okay here we you know this works this as
well we don't have that so now it's
important understand in this case it's
not that stochastic gradient descent
actually finds the empirical risk
minimizer the the regular empirical risk
minimizer okay what it does is just find
something that generalizes just as well
okay so if you think of it this way this
is maybe then you know the best thing
we're competing with the the best
predictor best low norm predictor okay
the best on the population okay so we
want to be close to it and with M
samples we can be squared B squared over
m close to it okay so we can be in some
neighborhood of fit okay
so erm is somewhere over here I mean
it's as good as we can get with em with
em samples to the appropriate to to the
truth okay if we run stochastic when you
send one pass to customary descent it's
nothing we're gonna get to the same
point here we're actually going to get
to a point it's also square root of B
squared over and away from w hat from
the RM so actually gonna be pretty far
from the RN but we're gonna be as close
to W star which is what we care about so
we get to within this neighbor that we
start all these three points are about
the same distance to one another okay
so the farm from Blissett organization
here is a bit different than than what
we saw before in the sense that it's not
the implicit organization it's how we
can say implicit revisor is minimizing
the squared norm okay like we saw before
that's minimizing the
based on rather it's getting
generalization in terms of this squared
norm it's achieving getting us to the
same neighborhood of the predictor with
men with the the recognized erm er the
predictor would small with bounded l2
norm
okay it pretty okay so is this is clear
okay good okay so what we should ask
ourselves then is where is the
reorganization hiding in stochastic
gradient descent why is to castigating
sent affording us organization relative
to the l2 norm right so he says that the
result of sequester unison will
generalize as well as the minimum l
2-norm solution hey are there so the
solution with constraint no tune on
we're going stood awhile to norm why not
L 1 norm or a nuclear norm or something
else I don't know sparsity okay how is
the this this in this bias towards small
nuclei on this generalization ability in
terms of the nuclear arm baked into
stochastic gradient descent or
integrating sent in general okay so
weird to see that let's think of what
what is actually stochastic gradient
descent so what we do in stochastic
grainy sending we're gonna set methods
we look at our objective we look at some
point and talk actually about grading
descent relevance because the newness in
perhaps and we use the gradient what is
the gradient the gradient gives us
linear approximation of our function in
each iteration of gradient descent we
can think of it as minimizing a linear a
first-order approximation a linear
approximation of our function I find
approximation of our function okay so if
we just did this is this a good
procedure okay what will happen if we
actually minimize this this is our what
this is this linear this first order
approximation to our objective what
happens if we minimize this first order
approximation no you're gonna get way
over here okay this is very bad why is
this bad because the Senor proximation
is only good around WT right over here
thus ending approximation is actually
pretty good over here it's horrible so
what we want to do is we want to
minimize our linear approximation but
still stay close to WT okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna minimize a
this regulation objective which is our
linear approximation plus some term that
says we're not gonna allow to get too
far away from WT how do we measure that
and this is the important thing here
we're going to measure that using the
the Euclidean norm and this is that
where the clearly normalization appears
in in grading centers to castigate
indecent right we do this this is now a
quadratic you can solve it and what you
get is exactly the the grading Center
stochastic gradient update depending of
GTS or gradient or stochastic gradient
estimate okay
okay so that means that so custom
gradient is sin is specifically works on
the Euclidean geometry and so maybe it
shouldn't be surprising that if we use
to Casting gradient we get
generalization properties in terms of
the Euclidean geometry in terms of your
clearly norm of W okay can we go beyond
Euclidean geometry okay so and so far we
saw that our sigh our bias was all given
by the Euclidean norm of W but what
about if you want to use a different
known no one nor the trace norm you know
some group k7 norm and something like
that okay okay so we have some some
regularizer site then at least if we
take an explicit approach it's pretty
clear what we should do what we should
do is either you know constrain our side
look at the sub level setter maybe you
use this formulation minimize the
empirical risk and sorry change notation
you know this is the empirical you know
change the empirical objective on the
empirical risk empirical objective on
the sample plus plus some the
organization side okay and if we do this
then in fact we can get good
generalization so in in particular if sy
is one strongly convex with respect to
some norm then we get generalization
which depends on sy off this predictor
you're competing with and the norm of
the gradient of F in the dual norm that
with respect to which besides strong
effects we'll see how this works out in
a second but we can get some translation
this comes so in this case for
supervised learning this is why there's
an L here and F here for supervised
learning problems we can get this marina
from convergence we can actually get
this for any convex problem and I think
I'm not think Sasha and Peter didn't
cover the I don't think they cover this
we can actually do this for any convex
problem but then we can you rely on your
from convergence we have to rely on
stability so it's different arguments
but still the result of explicit
organization okay how can we what
what would be the analog of stochastic
gradient descent here how can we get the
same type of her organization just by
running some optimization algorithm so
the right optimization algorithm to run
in this case where is it okay the rate
of translational going to run in this
case would be mirrored descent or dual
averaging or if you took my classes the
way I described is for the regulates
linearized leader it's all the same
algorithm okay what is it so what we're
doing maybe the easiest thing to think
about it is we have all these gradients
that we collected so each one of them
provides some linear approximation for a
function we're gonna average all of them
so we're gonna get this average of first
order approximation of our function okay
and we're gonna optimize this linear as
the this average linear approximation
with with the realization to him to
depend the that's given by this Poisson
okay what this boils down to is also
given by this maybe more familiar form
of Mirror descent which looks kind of
similar to the gradient descent we had
before that each time we're taking a
step where we're only looking at the
linear approximation around W we're only
looking at a linear approximation of WT
and now the way we have to look at how
you know how far we're moving is in
terms of the Bergen and divergence
associated with website but they don't
want to tell you what the Brethren
divergence is I don't like the bergen
divergence the very little variance
involves the dual and I think I promised
somebody this is gonna be a dual free
talk okay so I wrote here the finish of
Bergen divergence just because I knew
somebody would ask you what is the
barometric virgin sect people insist on
asking what is the path norm but
actually I'm not I don't want you to
think about the breadth of the
divergence okay so how actually should
you think about these things okay so so
let's think about the so this is the
mirror descent we saw before and
involves this bregman divergence which I
don't like okay but let's think of what
happens here if we take so at each step
we're going to minimize we're going to
look at a linear approximation there's
an approximation Plus this divergence
term so let's look at the second order
approximation of this divergence term so
if you look at the second order
approximation of this divergence term
when it comes down to is just this
quadratic norm given by the Hessian of
site so now if I solve
so now this is just a quadratic and I
can solve this and what I get is this
update in which instead of just going in
the direction of of F I go in the
direction of F what skewed by the
Hessian of site mean now note that this
is kind of a more correct in two ways so
gradient descent thing of grading
descent as you're just taking a step in
the direction of the gradient is a
completely wrong thing because the
gradient you're optimizing in some space
so I think of this is you know space of
column vectors and the gradient what's
the gradient the gradient is not a
vector the gradient is a is a the
leaning is in a dual space it's a yes
that's why I don't like a dual right but
the linear the graininess is a linear
functional on your space it's actually
if if your optimization there iterates
are our column vectors the grain is a
row vector okay so what you're doing if
you're just saying I'm adding the
gradient to my inner if you're adding a
row vector in a column vector and all
your gradient descent code should really
not refuse to compile because adding row
vectors and column vectors okay so what
you really should be doing is one of two
things in there thinking about it this
way this is fine this is correct because
now we're we're using the gradient here
only as it the weight you know God
intended us to use the gradient is a
linear functional and multiplying a row
vector in the column vector and now what
were what we're doing is we're just
minimizing this plus a proximity term
but this the way we're measuring the
local geometry is no now we're measuring
geometry but the geometry is local and
this Hessian up side determines our
local geometry it tells us at each
location which directions are expensive
to go in and which directions are cheap
to go in okay or this is equivalent to
think of it this way and now we have an
explicit transformation here mapping our
row vector to a column vector okay and
it's just the gradient descent this
happens to be an identity for some
particular types of faces okay good but
this is still not so this in this uptick
rows is known as natural gradient
descent so you can think of natural
green it's n is the second order
approximation to Mirror descent but then
this makes this fairly intuitive but how
do we get to I mean I mean why do I need
this if I'm only looking in
approximation so in order to see that
let's think of what happens here if we
take the steps
to zero so this is all in discrete time
let's move from discrete time to
continuous time so I'm going to take the
step size to zero so instead of these
discrete updates these boils down to a
note EE I know where the OD is given
where the the the the derivative of W
respect to T so W dot is proportional to
exactly the right hand side here the
gradient transformed by the Hessian of
site okay so this and this is valid for
either one of these I mean both of them
have the same limit when the step size
goes to zero so in the step this goes to
zero mirror descent and natural grading
Center are the same okay but the thing
is we do actually care about the screen
time because we're using discrete
computers or rounding things for you
know a discrete number of steps and we
do care about how many steps we run okay
so rather than starting from this and
going to this ODA the way I want you to
think about mirror descent is start from
this OD and and the reason I want you
think about that again we want to
emphasize the the geometry in to me here
the geometry is very explicit so this
sigh this Hessian of sy specifies the
local geometry very explicitly okay so
now there's this OD and we need to
discretize it so how do you discretize
this OD well the simplest thing to do is
do a kind of foreign Euler
discretization what does this boil down
to is thinking of this Oda as kind of
this piecewise linear OD so we take
every can I wear smacking whiteboard
here
so we took this Eau de and the solution
to all the ears you know some you know
smooth path and instead what we do is
for any for every time step of length
tell okay we fix the we fix the right
hand side here
hey so that that means that we take now
for a towel we take you know stepping
this in a fixed direction and here we
take a step in a fixed direction and
here we take a step to fix direction and
so forth
okay so is this this descritization
clear we're only changing alright inside
every towel time okay
in this if you solve this OD okay since
what you're doing is just taking a step
every towel time this is exactly natural
grain in descent okay how do you get
mirror descent so that's a better
discretization what we're gonna do is
we're gonna discretize this part just
the same but we're not going to
discretize this at all
and so what we're gonna do is this we're
going to look at a discretization of the
gradient of our objective because our
objective F is something we actually
need to ask about which it's a
complicated function we don't know it so
every time we're gonna query a gradient
if our objective okay but sighs
something that we already know it's
maybe easy for us to work with so we're
gonna leave this on discretized and
changes continuously so in get instead
of getting this piecewise linear thing
you're gonna get something which is it's
piecewise smooth I can throw it it can
grow piecewise smooth things its
piecewise smooth maybe look something
like this because each piece here okay
corresponds to still solving this OD II
just where where the red part is fixed
and the green part is still
time-dependent if you look at this risk
realization this discretization is
exactly equivalent to mirror descent
it's just another way to the right
mirror the same so another way to think
about near the sand is it's a better
discretization of this OD Y a better
discretization because we're
discretizing it list okay in in so this
is one you think about one year
descendants is better natural grain usin
in particular to actually get good
performance guarantees we have to
discretize in this way and not in this
way okay but both of them just stem can
be derived directly from
so d so here I mean the reason I like
this is this there's no dual here in the
Obermann divergence the the geometry is
very explicit here just a discretization
of using this local geometry okay great
so this is yes that's a good question I
don't know if you do so this is I should
say this is the right Bay Area and
myself what we don't know I mean we
talked about it I mean it's not
something very sophisticated right I
haven't seen it before I can tell you in
a rows actually when I had to explain
near the center physicists and you know
I I didn't even try going into the door
right so so they're not explained near
the center physicists you know you
should start with no D I I don't know
I'll be very happy to hear if the peers
before I've not seen this this is
reminding yes so this is right so this
is the reason I'm not looking so what
said the word said wants me to say is
I'm looking here at grating seven semi
menu and manifold with the local
geometry given by a website I'm willing
to say that the reason I'm not I I don't
feel frankly I don't feel comfortable
enough in my own understanding of very
many manifolds in order to say that
that's its agenda but like I know for
the day here
this vehicles for unconstraint that's
true so that's it that's a very good
question yeah that's a that's a very
good point so this is only for
unconstrained optimization in fact I
only going to be talking about
unconstrained optimization today and
it's a good question whether you can and
I think the answer is yes but we haven't
worked it out whether you can get a
similar view also for constrain near the
center maybe you know other the boundary
of the set because then you would have
this regularizer plus the indicator of
descent okay so I'm thinking of
constraints okay there gets a constraint
something up is a constraint to the
simplex where I'm constraining myself to
so it's so I don't have issues of
boundary but rather I'm concern yourself
to a lower dimensional manifold and in
that case I think things are
differentiable so I'm not sure this is
the short answer
okay then so so for now it's not gonna
be lower rank because we said the
precise to be strongly convex and if
it's low rank that this is undetermined
and you excite actually we'll get to a
situation like that in a second but for
now we're talking about beside being a
strongly convex and so the Hessian of
size small ring okay so this is the what
I did here is for a batch gradient
descent what happens with stochastic
gradient descent or so sorry that's me
Radisson what happens with stochastic
mirror descent
so for stochastic mirror descent I I
have the same thing you know just that
every time instead of taking the full
grading I'm just taking the the gradient
with respect to on a single in a single
observation ZT and again I can talk
about the second or approximation the
secondary profession gives me the
natural gradient ascent they're both
gonna have the same limit when the step
size goes to 0 and what is gonna be this
limit if we take the step size to 0 so
what do we get here so again we we take
the the same type thing now we we take
smaller and smaller steps so we tighten
small install steps in time okay so
what's going on is that not only are we
having finer and finer discretization
we're also using more and more and more
samples because in the same time scale
right I'm I'm gonna be using one over
tau in in one time I'm gonna using one
over tau samples so number of samples
are going to go to infinity here and the
the continuous limit we lost all
stochasticity the continuous limit is
just gradient flow in the population
okay so how can we but what we want to
do is go back what we want to go is
actually start from this is and the rise
back stochastic gradient centers to
Casting natural there's questions here
okay okay
so what we have to do here is in the
discretization explicitly discretize not
only the linearization but also
explicitly discretize the the
stochasticity and we can do this so we
can define this stochastic natural
Grandison stochastic period the center
particularly since no casting Aryan
descent as a discretization of this
gradient flow in a population so now
also every time not only are we updating
our gradient estimate but every tell
time we're also using a different
example okay so I think this is an
important of you to keep in mind and
comes in some recent work which also
suggests why I mean we said one of the
connections optimization here so how do
you want to choose this this geometry
you want to choose this geometry so that
the Eau de is as straight as possible
okay so if this is the place we're going
to end up with we prefer going this way
then going kind of something like this
okay because if we go something like
this it's going to be harder to
discretize so we're gonna have to need
more discretization steps okay if we go
like this we're gonna need less
discritization steps but also I think if
we think of it as stochasticity then you
can understand why it's also very
important that our past is short so we
said before that I'm gonna go you know I
want to choose and then the optimization
such that I'm gonna get to - I'm gonna
get to a nearby beach and I want to kind
of get there it's good for me with our
implementation such as I'm gonna get to
the optimum quickly why is it good it's
just intuitively it's good also in terms
of generalization because if I have
if I have a short way of getting
somewhere or a very long way of getting
somewhere
in this short way of getting somewhere
it can have fewer use fewer examples
okay and along the way instill the
variants introduce basic as this T is
not going to be very high if you have a
very very long path okay then I'm gonna
have to now have many many more use many
more and more samples remember that each
one of these steps also have to use in
another sample in order to get the same
roughly variance of the path maybe two
in fact in MIDI sample complexity by and
I don't know exactly how to do this I
mean in general but we could consider
something similar Bexley by studying
starting with this OD on the population
though the N population goes the
population optimum and now we can ask
how much we have to discretize this to
Christa city in order to still get
something labels close enough to the
Audion formulation and now I will kick
tell us how many samples we need in
order to optimize the population which
is our goal okay let's yes yeah you're
right so I'm not getting okay no no so
we're so two comments one is I thought
what you meant I'll get back to what you
actually said I thought what he meant
and that's true I don't actually care
about getting to the population often
really what I ask is how long will it
take me to get to a neighborhood an
episode neighborhood if equation up to
him and then I have to make sure that my
path after the after the stochasticity
would still get to this neighborhood I
think what would you actually asking is
before I was talking about this
underdetermined situation and now the
population objective the problem is not
under determined the problem is under
determined only on the sample because I
have many more many fewer samples than
parameters but in the population the
problem is nicely fully determined okay
so the population optimum is unique or
well defined at least or at least any
population object the optimum is good
for me okay so the game here okay maybe
the last question
this point about the length of okay I
didn't either we're crystal things it
figured out they will have longer
physically so in fact in fact I don't
understand momentum methods and I and we
try to talk about this area I think
before and I I don't I don't completely
I there's been lots so there's been lots
of work on understanding this so non
stochastic deterministic discrete
optimization methods by using this
discretization in particular
understanding momentum methods in this
context okay what I'm suggesting here
they're just giving context here what
I'm suggesting here is trying to
understand stochastic methods in
particular sample complexity also using
the screws asian and the comment is that
the length of the path is not really the
important thing but maybe because in
momentum methods if you look at the
descriptors that the type of path that
you can add them you that corresponds to
adding momentum it's actually crazier
path in in fact that's why I don't
completely understand the derivation of
the momentum methods using
discretization so you're right that the
length of the path is not like the the
time is meaningless I can always get
faster in shorter time just by right so
you this is why I didn't actually do
this right so this is I mean we can talk
about it later and try to understand
what's my money okay let's go back to
the geometry so the game here is what we
want is to match to find the geometry
that matches our problem okay so what
geometry would match are probably best
well I can tell you they actually know
the objective function there's a very
clear geometry which is the best
geometry which is what using years ago
just say equals if so if you say equals
f then natural grading descent
corresponds to Newton method which is
not bad mirror descent will be much
better mirror design will just be done
in one iteration okay so that's
definitely the best thing you can do
okay and fortunately easily done though
our objective because otherwise we don't
need to optimize at all and so we have
some in certainly and what we want is to
find
upside that kind of matches our sense of
the problem as best as we can so the way
should think of it is roughly suppose we
don't know where the optimum is we don't
know where W is okay but we have maybe
some censuses are kind of prior
knowledge just to think of this is our
hypothesis class so you want to capture
okay now if you prefer thinking of like
you're some complexity measure then
maybe this is not a fixed type artistic
West but you have some complexity
measure that finds the hierarchy of
hypothesis classes it's not so important
the game here is we want to find is a
EPs ID that strongly convex that is as
small as possible and is strongly convex
and easy to work with
that's as small as possible roughly
speaking but still captures W so I think
if the sub level setups I might look
something like this this is pretty good
we capture our the models we really want
to capture pretty well and now to
understand the complexity what we have
to go is we have to go to the talent
fortune we do have to go to the dual in
some sense what you have to do is think
this is strongly convex especially some
norm and now we have to see how can we
capture the gradients of our objective
in the dual norm for which this is
strongly convex respective mean that's
what's going to determine the complexity
so the balance of the value of sy under
w's and the evaluation of the dual norm
on the gradients okay okay and I should
say that this view is in some sense
general and universal in the following
sense then if you have a problem it's
specified by some plausible region of
W's in possible set of of gradients then
the approach we just saw is optimal
meaning that you can always get them the
min/max optimal sample complexity okay
in some sense by it comes by choosing
the right side there always exists some
site that will give you the min max
optimal complexity both you either when
you use it as as
implicitly for in the optimization
algorithm namely in mirror the
cemetery's psi or is an explicit
regulator okay so let's let's maybe see
it a bit more concretely so we said that
their complexity looks something like
this we have to choose subsided dances
so two things in the gradient of F at
least for supervised learning problems
the gradient of F basically just posed
to the data point the gradient of F is
just X if we have a linear predictor and
so really you should think about it you
want to look at psy off the the W star
you want to compete with and dual norm
on the data okay and so the standard
choice is to choose the Euclidean
geometry so if you work in the Euclidean
geometry the sample complexity is given
by the squared square norm of W times a
square number fix okay that's fine
so changing the geometry now corresponds
to an the easiest way to think of a
change in geometry is a geometry that's
you know where the Hessian is fixed at
worst and it's just a different
quadratic geometry do you clean in
geometry under two different basis so
that's given by I which has this
quadratic form okay and that means that
when we can think of this as
precondition gradient descent right
integrating descent we use a fix
transformation Q so we just work with a
different basis and now our sample
complexity is going to be given by the Q
norm of W and the q inverse norm of X
okay so now if you think of what's the
best queue to work with you want to find
if you have you want to find an
ellipsoid Q that captures your that's
kind of fits the fits your prior notion
about W well and that it's dual fits you
know contains the data well roughly
speaking okay okay so this is kind of
still quadrant geometries but you can do
that with other geometries so for
example you can look at LP norms and so
the LP norm the squared LP norm is not
one strongly convex respect to P no to
make it one strongly convex you have to
scale this Weiss you have to take 1 over
P or P minus 1 times the squared LP norm
that is strongly convex about 2p norm
and so the Sam book of X do you get is
the the LP norm of W the dual norm of
the data so that makes sense divided by
P minus 1
this is also fine but the problem the
the interesting case is the L 1 and L 1
norm P equals 1 doesn't work here
because prevail one or the denominator
then denominator goes to infinity and we
get or it goes to 0 that the whole thing
explodes ok and this is really the most
interesting case how do we handle the L
1 geometry so they're two approaches
here are the many approaches one
approach is we can actually take an LP
norm where P is very close to 1 okay P
is roughly 1 over log D is good enough
ok but sorry 1 1 plus 1 over log P sorry
no okay but the other approach is to
take this entropic potential so if you
take sorry to be in surf l1 or it's time
for W guys instead of taking self a WI
log W I me then this is one strongly
convex the least in the restriction of
the space with method 1 norm in what we
get here is the same convexity is going
to behave this the gun pen and ly norm
and infinity norm x log D so this is a
familiar sample code because if really
one or and get surgery is going to be
optimal but I want to focus in the
geometry here so what happens here again
we compute in terms of the OD and if you
just look you know it just boils down to
calculating the Hessian of sine and
plugging it in if you calculate the
Hessian up side action up sighs the
diagonal of 1 over W okay and so we get
an OD that looks like this so in each
coordinate instead of the gradient
determined by the the DDT determined by
the grading DDT is determined by w times
the gradient so what we're doing is
multiplicative weights right where every
time we're we're multiplying our update
by the current value of W and this
exactly bows down to multiple good
weights okay so what we saw here is we
we changed our what what you're supposed
to get from this part of the tutorial is
I'm trying to explain what I mean by
geometry and how by changing the
geometry of the optimization right so
this geometry sigh of the optimization
we're getting inductive biases in terms
of generalization in terms of different
quantities that correspond to this to
this geometry and now this goes back
maybe to the question of what happens if
size nuts only convicts so all this all
the theoretical analysis wrists and side
being yes
we convex which means that the geometry
is well-conditioned everywhere okay but
you know maybe we can throw that off the
door instead of that just say oh well
really the simple way to interpret all
this is what I do at each step this is
maybe going and you know D is a
continuous version of this but what
happens in each step is I want to take
an infinitesimal step and they want to
do it in four decimal step in two things
I want to take infinitum step that
improves the objective as much as
possible this is captured by main linear
approximation or approximate linear
approximation it is also small okay so I
want to take like it smell the step that
it can I mean I want to make the most
progress in the least sized step and the
question is how do I measure small step
okay so this is where the geometry comes
in okay so before we measure it small
step in terms of now I'm going to be are
going to measure stop small step in
terms of this Euclidean distance given
by sorry a local distance local Romanian
distance here I said it given by Q okay
but now you can say well maybe I have
any type of measure distance as in every
distance any type of way of saying what
how big a step is how big is WT is how
you know step from WT WT is and I can
just define my step is taken each
iteration a step that's small in terms
of this Delta and makes the most
progress and that's what I define then
that's called steepest descent in again
you can think about it as a
generalization of mirror descent where
we through analysis out the door okay
okay and in this case so if we take the
Euclidean distance maybe should say
finding distance square here hey then
what we get back is exactly gradient
descent because that's what we saw
before and now we can get things that
are definitely not strongly convex and
again the most interesting thing to take
is stupid is the l1 norm
okay and now what do I get now if I do
steep descent respect to what I'm saying
so I want to take a step that smallest
in terms of L 1 hour and makes the most
progress hey the way to do that is to
just use a single coordinate and up and
and put all my money on a single
coordinate ok so that goes down to
coordinate descent you know in what
emphasize the coordinate sent is not
well-defined okay because exactly
because this distance is not strongly
convex in what sense is not well-defined
I might have ties right there might be
multiple ways of making the same amount
of progress ok on different coordinates
there have two coordinates that both
have the same partial derivatives I can
make the same amount of
of progress if you choose one coordinate
or the other coordinate or any
combination of them so there actually
many different valid coordinate descent
paths okay so that's what happens if you
don't have strong convexity okay okay
but and so whenever we say and now I'm
going to say coordinate descent quite a
bit in this talk and you should keep in
mind whenever you're saying coordinate
descent it's actually ill-defined okay
we might Sun coordinate descent okay you
can also do this Roger non non strongly
convex distance measures like the
elephant in arm and what you get here is
kind of this just looking at taking step
in the direction when you design for the
gradients okay okay okay so what do we
have
okay so what do we see so far so what we
saw so far you might be wondering why
you know what is the maybe somebody even
asked this what is the connection
between everything I told you now in all
the motivation I had in the beginning
because in the beginning so what we saw
so far is I call this implicit
organization that's very really very
different then the implicit organization
rasili to get this implicit organization
it was important and we're doing a one
pass stochastic method okay so you can
think of that as kind of early stopping
we're not optimizing to convergence we
did not get the training error down to
zero right so after this one passed it
said we're not at empirical risk
minimizer okay we still have substantial
training error okay in the number of
Federation's in particular is equal to
the number of data points okay this is
very different from the phenomenon we
saw at the beginning which is a
phenomena where we either use some batch
master that we use maybe stochastic
gradient we use many many passive
stochastic gradient and actually drove
down the optimization to zero that's not
what we saw so far okay or it's not even
this it's not you can think of it also
in the boosting example we mentioned
boosting can be viewed as
so add a boost at least is a batch
coordinate descent method so what it
does is does coordinate descent but it's
batch core you said not stochastic or
innocent so again all this discussion we
had so far is kind of irrelevant for for
adaboost okay
and again that the the performance of
the this behavior fighter bus who sees
after the training error was with zero
so so what we're gonna turn to maybe
we'll take the break a few minutes
earlier like two minutes earlier right
what we're going to turn to after the
break is we're gonna still talk about
convex problem but now still talk about
convex problems but now we're gonna turn
from this stochastic optimization where
we get the implicit organization by
virtue of early stopping and an instead
turn to these underdetermined problems
where we are going to optimize using
batch or some other method all the way
down and we're gonna see how how that
also gives us good enough inductive bias
to allow generalization so let me just
before we go to break just maybe justify
why did we do all this because what
we're going to see is this so the main
thing I hope you got from all this is
this connection between a geometry and
optimization oh I should have had my
slide in this disappeared okay so this
connection between optimization geometry
and learning okay so the optimization
since what we're talking about is just
low called optimization algorithms I
know our basically local search
optimization algorithms if anything
we're going to talk about and so in this
locus learn the the algorithm is
determined by the geometry you know the
difference between algorithms well down
to different geometries that were
working with
how did I measure the small step size
and also for a learning problem really
what we should care about is what is
this geometry of this hypothesis space
how does it look like does it look like
a you cleaning ball does it look like a
simplex doesn't know what is this
geometry in the space and we say we saw
that good things happen when the
geometry of the Euclidean if the
optimization problem matches the the
geometry of the learning problem in
particular we have reusing we're doing
grading we're doing optimization respect
to some geometry and we get
generalization with respect to the
hypothesis class defined by that
geometry and I'm using here geometry
very very loosely which is also maybe
you wanna rather not use the term and in
geometry because they don't think that
would have been correct what I just said
okay so we'll take a break and after the
break well show you said we'll tell you
how long it'll be we'll turn to these
undetermined problems
[Applause]